Donald Trump gave an interview yesterday
and he again did this bizarre n-word
rant this is his new bit he knows
exactly who his audience is and this was
an interview in which Donald Trump
seemed very confused quite disoriented
take a listen if you look at Putin with
his talk
in
mentioned that thing that thing that we
don't want to talk about I say the
n-word well it means the nuclear word
the n-word is the nuclear word and that
is a threat like nobody's had out there
I mean he's talking about that openly
and it's being handled very badly I
agree with you I think that shouldn't
have happened very badly from within
Trump knows exactly who his audience is
he knows exactly how to wind people oh
the n-word the n-word and you might
remember that clip from his rally over
the weekend where Trump brought up the
n-word and he goes you know what that is
and then the crowd thinks they know
which n-word he's talking about and then
Trump has to pacify them and go no no no
no no no I mean nuclear I mean nuclear
or nuclear as some like to say uh Donald
Trump seems to think that Putin is
winning in Ukraine despite a protracted
stalemate at best for Russia right now
Mr President if you get reelected let's
just say hypothetically here you get
back in what would you do to broker
piece right away because I don't hear
anybody from the European Union and
definitely in the Biden regime trying to
convince these two zelinski and Putin to
get to the table and do what's right for
the innocent people die by the way
before Trump delivers his foreign policy
analysis this is on oan Trump is
increasingly relegated to being
interviewed on Newsmax and oan fox had
him last week to try to help him out but
he is increasingly not welcome on
mainstream networks in the middle which
is come to the peace marketing table
nobody's willing to discuss that
well it would have been much easier
before it happened but it did happen and
that's where we are right now the thing
you have to do is get the oil price down
and Russia will stop because Russia is
getting at a hundred dollars a barrel
Russia has never had they've never had
wealth like this before and despite the
war in the cost of the war what the war
is doing to everybody and The Killing
if you got oil down to you know I had it
down to forty dollars a barrel I had it
down to less than that we had gasoline
at one point remember the the collapse
in the oil Market was because of covet
now Trump is praising it like it's a
good thing down to uh a dollar and 49
cents can you believe it I remember now
you look at where it is you look at
where it is right now everybody was
buying very big cars and trucks they
were driving trucks they wanted not even
SUVs let's go buy a truck but we had it
down to a level that nobody's seen in
decades and decades and decades and it
was a great thing this country was
booming and then they shut it off but
what you do is you have to get the oil
price down you get the oil price down
the the uh you get it down to 40 50 a
barrel the war would stop automatically
you don't even have to talk to anybody
would stop automatically now of course
this entire framing is completely absurd
Trump seems to think Putin is actually
winning in Ukraine despite the reality
on the ground being dramatically
different but you're not going to get
pushed back on oan they're not they're
certainly not going to push back about
that now one interesting moment was that
you know oan is one of the most
weaponized disinformation audiences that
is out there in right-wing media on oam
on oan Trump stood by the vaccines for
covid as well as operation warp speed
which I don't know that the audience
here is necessarily going to love but
remember Trump is desperate to have
something to take credit for uh as far
as uh operation warp speed I mean I've
been given great reviews on that by a
lot of people we've done that we did an
incredible job you know what we handed
it back over after a rigged election we
handed it back over the stock market was
higher than it was prior to covet the
day before covet came in and by the way
the stock market is higher than it is
right now I don't know if anybody's
noticed that yeah we've lost 7 trillion
since Biden took over yeah I was going
to get to that in the economy but I
still got to get that vaccine question
Out Mr President just because I get so
many viewers asking with the side
effects where does Mr Trump stand on
that the the side effects guys the side
effects which are what again just blue
like a little bit so many viewers sent
that in to me so we got a vaccine done
and we also got regeneron and a lot of
other therapeutic things done which are
phenomenal and which really remember
Trump didn't do any of those things the
uh you know people don't talk about but
really uh have been fantastic uh the
vaccine was done in nine months instead
of five years or ten years or 12 years
and as you know there are many many
people that think that millions of
people worldwide have been saved because
of the the vaccine uh we'll see what
happens we're going we're looking at it
very very closely but we got that done
in nine months as opposed to five years
to 12 years I said who's going to take
anywhere from five to twelve years if
re-elected though Mr President you would
remove any type of mandate at the
federal level for our military for first
run for everybody when it comes to this
vaccine because there are questions
about the side effects so you would
write it there are really no questions
Amanda
were done by Governors and they were
done by others and the mandates were
very bad I was against the mandates I
was never before the mandates and all
right so for you know he's trying to
court an audience on oan that is not big
on the vaccines that's the reality and
um I don't know how that's going to
necessarily go over with them but Trump
has very little left and he just doesn't
even know where to go uh Donald Trump uh
continuing the theme from his rallies of
the anti-tran stuff during this
interview as well this thing has
exploded like it's okay and normal to
start cutting up a 13 or a 14 year old
and use 140 different genders and 200
different pronouns this is nonsense
they're going after our kids don't you
think Mr President
true and I ended that as you know I
ended it largely in the country but I
ended it for our military it was over
you couldn't do it right and there was a
little bit of fuss from a few people but
99 of the people agreed this is a very
this is an issue that if you ever took a
real poll it probably would pull at one
percent yes and they're trying to
destroy our country so this is now a
theme this is you know we started seeing
this actually at CPAC where the biggest
Applause lines were the overtly
homophobic and transphobic ones and
we're increasingly seeing this and it's
a really depressing thing to see absent
any actual policy last clip here
uh trumpers as well as Trump himself
want to paint a picture of the golden
age of America the summer of covet even
though it was actually the summer of
covid and we're not that far away we had
something going so special two years ago
we were leading the world in every
category every group within our country
is leading African-American Asian
American women men Hispanics everybody
was leading young people old people we
were all doing great yeah remember that
that was when hospitals needed to bring
in refrigerated trucks as morgues
because they were out of space for the
people dead from covet in the hospitals
another bizarre interview
completely disconnected from reality
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself for
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than this
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the raise laser to get the hair out I
use Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman at a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below